Now, let me do a brief addendum to the Donald
Trump UN general assembly speech. This is
just a short little thing. I mentioned earlier
that Donald Trump's speech in terms of its
tone was very bizarre in terms of its content.
It was disgusting, but it was also so low
energy that Donald Trump's cabinet secretary
Wilbur Ross, the commerce secretary slept
through the speech. Now, Wilbur Ross has slept
through speeches before. He's in his eighties
he may just be a really tired guy. Take a
look at this video.
For this same reason we have pursued bald
diplomacy on the Korean peninsula. I have
told Kim Jong UN,
okay,
what I truly believe that like around his
country is full of tremendous untapped potential.
If you are merely listening and not watching
as Donald Trump did that extremely low energy,
a a teleprompter reading, Wilbur Ross was
visibly sleeping. And again, there are reports
out from months ago about Wilbur Ross generally
sleeping through meetings pretty frequently.
So this isn't new, but yet just you know,
the, the entire big picture of it, Trump in
the most low energy downer Trump mode that
we've maybe ever seen a cabinet secretary
literally sleeping during it while the rest
of the world watches in sort of confused horror
about the ridiculous things that Donald Trump
is saying. We got to get this guy out. We've
got to get them out, uh, by voting in November
of 2020 the impeachment will not lead to a
Senate conviction of Trump. We've got to get
them out because it's just embarrassing. It
is embarrassing to be a citizen or resident
of a country where this guy is the president
and even Wilbur Ross unable to stay awake
for it.